okay everybody I think it's ten o'clock
so I'm going to get started so we're
talking about the wolfram compiler this
morning we've actually got there's the
talk I'm giving which go this talk goes
from now until 11 o'clock and then
there's another talk from 11 to 11:30
we're fitting in a few different people
so I'm going to talk for about 45
minutes and then some some of the other
team the group of us that work on the
compiler we're gonna be talking
brenton will join into my talk will
finish that at 11 o'clock with a sort of
summary and then we'll start another
talk on the compiler with Abdul and I
might wrap up with some more material we
won't be taking any questions at the end
of this first talk we'll save all the
questions for the end or we could carry
over to 2 to lunch because there's
there's there's quite a lot to talk
about right now so this is the new the
Wolfram compiler it's a new technology
to enhance the core of the Wolfram
language and we're going to be looking
over this this is a long term project
I've been talking about this at I've
been talking about compilation in
general Wolfram language for many years
but this particular project I've been
showing you advances in this over the
past few years it's a long term project
eventually it's going to replace the old
compiler with a completely new
implementation and it's built in the
Wolfram language but it's I'm pleased to
say I hope this is there's an initial
version the first release of the
compiler is going to be included in
version 12 and I'm using a version 12
right now
so there's definitely going to be some
rough edges and some things not quite
finished but we believe that we've got
something that's useful and powerful and
a thing to move forwards with so I'm
going to look at general features the
compiler some of the internals
and then I'll be looking and Brenton and
Abdul also be looking at some examples
of how interesting programs that we can
write with the compiler um now who who
who is interested in a Wolfram compiler
or a compiler for the Wolfram language
different sorts of people the one set of
person Oh everybody right fine good
fantastic
right and I'm just trying to set the
scene to say what what our motivations
so there's just ordinary users ordinary
in a general sense of wolfram engines
and things and they they're going to
benefit with just automatic compilation
through functions like plot or or such
like and as we move forwards we can
start to rework a lot of existing
features like the pattern matcher or
library link and things like that we can
we can rework with our compiler
technology so another category of person
is people who actually use the compiler
a lot of people I know that come to a
conference such of this you know they
try to use compiled in their programs to
try to make things faster and they're
willing to do some tweaking and such
like to make things conform I think now
moving forwards there's another category
or Anik you know going on from that and
that's the people who might be
interested in sort of extending the
compiler and there are ways of extending
it of adding new data types and adding
libraries and special optimizations
I think that's that's quite interesting
the compiler has a lot of potential for
integrating with other languages so
people who are not necessarily
interested in compilation of the Wolfram
language they want to integrate other
things into other languages are the
technologies into Wolfram language and
it has a lot of potential for that and a
last set of people
all is people can developers and
researchers and I think that people
doing research in CS departments and
such like I think this is a great
technology for developing new special
optimizations proving things leveraging
new some of the technology behind you
know compilation systems and it's like I
think we've there's some potential here
right now let's just dive in this is the
main this is what Steven showed the sort
of main initial way to use the compiler
is there's a new thing called function
compile so it's different syntax and
function compile takes a a function a
pure function and it returns a an
optimized sort of you know a compiled
code function that will execute your
your function now if you give it some
you know different it's not you get an
argue you know an error so this is
supposed to be integers to integers
I gave it a boolean you get an error if
you so what's supported so core natives
types you know integers reals complex
Bacteroides um but we're also supporting
different sizes like unsigned integer a
turn real 32 these sorts of things
they're they're actually manifest in
numeric array which is a new feature
coming out in version 12 there are some
talks on numeric array they're also
useful for like machine learning often
wants to solve you know solves problems
using smaller floating-point point sizes
so we support many standard programming
features nested functions closures
errors are propagated with Hardware
exceptions so we try to be make a very
modern language implementation variety
of output targets and we have a
documented official callback mechanism
to the war from evaluator for things
that don't currently fit in you know a
fullback a bridge for things that don't
currently fit into the compiler so just
go through some of the types that we're
supporting we have I don't be too
technical in this but we're supporting
you know a bunch of atomic types well
maybe complex isn't really an atomic
type so we have things like that
compound types so patter a is the sort
of initial version so you have a packed
array is a type but it's a type that
takes other types to sort of you know
become some become useful and so this is
a packed array and it's being given an
integer 64 and this is like a type
literal so this is like a dependent type
and this is saying it's a vector and
this here is a complex real 64 this is a
packed array of real complex numbers and
it has two integers so it's a matrix so
that's that's that so we have a function
type so you can see the function type we
a little bit small there but it's like
you know t1 yes sorry I don't know how
to yeah I don't know how to zoom that
sorry I'm using some style sheet in the
zoom button I don't have a zoom button
so sorry right this is a function type
and it's specified with a list and a raw
so these are the arguments and this is
the output
that's function type and then we have
more other internal types integrating
with C and C++ libraries we also have a
polymorphic which is a quantifier
we're probably not documenting that in
in version one but internally we use it
a lot
so Pachter a support oh there we go
right there we know I do know how to do
right so this is a I've got a function
and it's been given a packed array of
reels and I'm applying fold
so I'm doing a fold operation and this
is the you know it's just like some
marching down through the patter a
applying applying a function to it so
that's now here's a way that the
compiler is completely different in more
advanced than the old compiler and
that's the way that it deals with nested
sort of inner functions and I'm going to
show you some sort of internal this is
our sort of internal intermediate code
that we compile into as part of the
compilation process so we have here I've
got like an inner function and that's
that's held as a variable then I'm
applying it to an argument so all I'm
doing all I have to give is for type
inferencing the the type of the input
and everything else gets gets gets
figured out what what happens and we can
use these you know here I can you know
we have very good just natural support
for this so I can use these functions as
data so I've got a condition I can say
depending on the condition it's this one
well this one that gets applied I can
have like here I've got a function so
this is a function that returns a
function and you know like we can see so
here we've got the type of this so this
is a function it takes no arguments but
it returns a function so have functions
that return functions we can have
functions I mean you just sort of carry
on sort of arbitrarily with this here's
function you know we passed a function
in and then we passed it as an argument
and it comes back and this this this
this all works now this might sound you
know a bit exotic but actually it's it's
it's actually quite powerful and this is
new to you new to our compiler another
new technology that we've added is
support for what you might call closure
variables so here I've got some in a
nested function and this is referring to
a local variable that comes higher up in
another function that's wrapped around
it this is like called the closure
variable and and we support we support
this now this sounds abstract but it's
actually very useful not least as a way
of encapsulation this is a way of
correctly dealing with global data and
this I'll show some good examples of
this in later in my talk so yet another
thing that we can support using this
mechanism we can support recursive
definitions of functions it might be a
bit hard to read but so what we I'm
using module to get recursive
definitions now really I'd rather use
width but we don't have a recursive
version of width this is like in other
languages have a thing called like let
rec we we don't have a construct like
that but i'm using i'm using module for
this so here I've got a function
oops and called fact pun and in fact fun
I'm referring to itself now this is in
maybe I shouldn't talk about this
because it's most people aren't
interested in but I this is in the
theory of lambda calculus such things
you know these let rec constructs are
actually created by these these W or Y
Combinator's depending upon what sort of
language you're you you're you're
working with and it's one of the wonders
of the world
things that you could implement
recursion without having to give
functions names so this is really just
syntax sugar for for these these these
combinators now what's also very
satisfactory is that I'm compiling this
down the only type i've given is the
input type I've got a recursive function
but it's able to give a complete the
type inferencing system is able to
determine the you know the type of the
whole thing and so I can you know do you
know generate executable code that works
and I think that's that's we were pretty
pleased when we got that to work now
again all of this sounds a bit academic
but it is not it's quite profound and
it's a-you know in the modern world this
is a much more modern way of programming
and it's you know it's like I said it's
an important way to encapsulate data it
allows you to built this is a lot of the
benefit of modern languages that have
lambda like JavaScript for example and
it allows you to build up a style of
programming that's similar to sort of
the old you know class object-oriented
style it's sort of equivalent to that
but it's it's you know it so it's much
more modern and powerful for various
technical reasons and also I might say
passing these functions is essential so
here we can be central for any sort of
parallel operations
that's just goes without saying now look
at some other features variety of
different outputs are possible so here I
got this is like we do function compile
and we get this compiled code function
coming back which which executes now if
we have a look at this input form we've
got this is the compiled code function
we've got some sort of metal
here and then we've got some some
numbers here these are these are
actually function addresses so it's
compiled this down to machine code
that's loaded into the environment and
we can talk about how how how this is
done but this is actually executing
native native assembler code just as if
you wrote a C program and invoked a C
compiler and made an executable but it's
doing this sort of dynamically as we
request it and so this means that the
default way of operating is entirely the
same as the old compilation target goes
to C which I know you know at least some
of you would work what you know used to
you used to make use of this so how does
how does this work we use this thing
called LLVM and that's that's this
underlying technology and LLVM has this
intermediate representation that's like
a platform dependent assembler and so
here I've got a function that I can see
here and it's got you know we've got two
functions here this is the main function
here and then this is the this sort of
inner function that's in here and we can
talk about if anyone's interested in the
structure of this it's written in this
form all of our intermediate code is
written in this compiler form that we
call single static assignment and that
is its it has this interesting property
it's a little bit like a lambda calculus
form that sort of folded inside out and
that's how modern compilers do things
anyway so we can generate this
intermediate form and then we can also
go one stage further and generate actual
assembler so this is the assembler for
that function so we've got various calls
to runtime libraries and jumps
and you know it's calling functions and
things so this is getting closer to
what's what's actually executed now we
have a target system option so I can
generate there we go and this is
generated and this is we can change this
to you know other you know later if
assembler for other platforms and you
know generate this webassembly stuff and
this is this sort of assembler that
executes in in browsers that's kind of
interesting hopefully something will be
able to make use of in our cloud
products we can also use function
compile export we can write into a file
so I can write this this is basically an
object file so we can we can look at
this boring but this is an object file
this is what your C compiler produces
you could link to this with a C program
or a C+ program and it would execute and
again we've got the same target system
options one of the good things about
LLVM is it's quite cross-platform so you
could you know compile code on one
platform for another if if you were
interested so another feature we support
is generating a shared library so now
I've taken the function here and I'm
writing it into a a library now this
library I can load it in and I get a
compiled code function that I can use so
one benefit of this is I can I don't
need to recompile the code every time I
can just make this compile code this
this library and loaded in with library
function load
and use it each time another benefit I
could link to this library from external
code as well which which is also useful
now so other backends the time we've
worked all loaded backends some of these
backends that we're developing
don't use don't use LLVM at all this is
one where we have our own intermediate
code and then we can turn it into a C
program so this is not not involving
LLVM this is just going straight from
our code into into C so that's kind of a
nice way you see in the old compiler
what we did was we had our bike code we
would generate C and then we would
compile that but what we're doing is
we're going in the opposite way we have
our compiled code we're generating our
bike code and then we can only convert
that into assembler or we convert that
into C code so that's but actually
generating the C code it's not so useful
because you can just make a make a
library now one of the things that
people have long thought about with the
compiler is you know they always worry
what can be compiled what can't be and
that's kind of an issue and we've added
a mechanism to you know work with the
native evaluator internals of the
wolfram engine and so we can there's a
type this is more of an internal thing
but I'll just show you roughly that so
we can make a function and we can give
the arguments the type expression and
this is going to work for numbers it'll
work for big numbers so these are not
machine numbers it'll work for symbolic
types of things so this is you know
using the sort of internal war from
expression
in ISM it's probably it comes with a
price because it's not not very
standalone it's tied to the Wolfram
engine now we've used this to implement
this thing called kernel function and
the kernel function is a bridge between
evaluated and compiled code so here so
we have support for I'll talk about in a
bit for things like Bessel function but
suppose you knows some function that's
not supported
you don't think supported we've added so
you add a kernel function for it and you
give it a type and you pass in the
arguments and so you do this and then
this is going to be your you know kind
of thing so that's what they're the same
so this is way of integrating evaluate
evaluator code in in compiler which
which i think is kind of useful and you
can use the you know you can use the
kernel function you can also give it a
pure function just has to be a function
and it has to meet this signature so and
[Music]
you can also use the kernel function as
a you know as a function object that
gets gets passed around so you can use
the same quite useful if you want to do
the same thing many times you can just
give it a name and then refer to it in a
but you know in a bunch of different
ways so here I've got this function and
dependent you know I'm applying it to
different arguments in in my program and
you can also have this kernel function
can itself return a function so I've got
an example here I've got another example
that I kind like here this is a bit sort
of complicated but there's many things
in wolfing language like nd solve that
return itself returns the function and
so nd soul returns and in turn
creating function so here I've got an ND
soul and that's returning so the
interpolating function so I can solve a
differential equation once and then I
can use the interpolating function that
comes back multiple times in my compiled
code and I think this is kind of a nice
integration with the with the system so
what kind of run this and right so we've
this is the this is the initial
condition so and this is what am i doing
I'm evaluating this right this is the
initial condition sorry this is the
initial condition and this is the value
of T so not surprising when I evaluate
the thing at the first point I get back
the initial condition so and you know
it's really calling the you know this is
going up to 30 so if I was to make this
you know 200 then I would get the
interpolating function you know sort of
error that comes out because that's an
it so this this this is pretty useful so
kernel function is an extension
mechanism where we don't have native
compiled code so yeah right so I just
thought now a little bit about the
compiler pipeline that we have so we
start with you know the Wolfram language
function programs and we go through
various steps as a tree we generate this
intermediate code we do type inferencing
we resolve through linking of functions
and suchlike
and then we generate an executable so
here for example I'm generating the
intermediate untyped intermediate code
so there's no type I'm given any type
annotations and I've just got generic
names
for these functions so we can do type
inferencing on this so now I've you know
figured out that times of you know two
integers returns an integer and so does
you know sort of plus and then that's
the that's the that's the result but I
haven't said which plus and then the
final thing is I resolve function calls
and now I specialize generates you know
more code but I've specialized the plus
to a particular times to a particular
times that works for you know sort of
integers and such like and then the
final stage is to do cogeneration and
come up with a compiled code function
now again a lot of the internals of the
is we have all these passes that do all
sorts of different this this is how we
implement the compiler we have all these
passes that do some of these do
optimizations you know fusing basic
blocks and remove you know removing
redundant code and jumps and things
right so the compilers built on top of
this LLVM technology so a lot of people
haven't really heard of some people have
some people haven't so LOV M is evolving
as the standard technology for compiler
one of the very leading structure
compiler infrastructures it's the basis
of the clang C and C++ compilers but it
has a lot of support from you know I
mean on Apple use it and Microsoft using
it in IBM and many companies when they
want to do some sort of end video when
they want to do some things they base
their tools around LLVM and we're able
to we're able to use it and there's a
lot of you know a lot of work that we
get a lot of benefits from that
right talk a little bit about the tight
framework so the tight framework is the
idea so we have a static static typing
we're giving we give type annotations
typically on the input exterior input to
functions and then we do inferencing so
we can determine types throughout the
throughout the function and that means
you don't have to put you know type
annotations in lots of places makes it
makes it quite convenient we also
support a thing called parametric
polymorphism and that means that I'll
explain a little bit what that is a
little bit of code can go a long way and
the type system actually is independent
of the compiler so there's no it has no
dependency on the compiler the compiler
uses it but not not the other way around
type theory is also there's a it's quite
tied to there's this correspondence
between pilot type theory and the math
and logic mathematical logic and one of
the there's a relation that's somewhat
similar to sort of type theory of doing
theorem proving and there's there's
people that Wolfram research that do
work in in in they're improving they're
improving is kind of like the opposite
direction so in theorem proving I think
you start with a type and that's kind of
your theorem and if you can find a
lambda function that has that type
that's equivalent to a proof of your
theorem we you know in the computer
science world we do the easier the much
easier task is we start with a program
we start with the lambda it's
essentially a lambda function and then
we figure out what what it's type is is
it well typed and what is what is the
type so that's that's kind of like the
forward problem as you know inverse
problems are harder than forward
problems you
integration is harder than
differentiation so we have the easy the
easy direction now a little talk about
polymorphism this is how we write a lot
of our code internally I've written here
a a function so it takes a packed array
and it's you know this it's basically
adding up all the parts is like total
now I've written it here but you know I
could write another version you know
like say with real 64 so the the program
all I've had to change is the type
progress the program is is the same
wouldn't it be nice if I didn't have to
sort of you know cut and paste all these
all these you know names and yes it
would be that's why a polymorphic so
here I've written the function I've not
given it any type type signatures what
I'm using here is a quantifier so this
is the same as a quantifier in in in in
logic or in here I'm giving it a type
variable so this is saying it's gonna
work for a packed array but I haven't
said what sort of Pat array is it it's a
packed array of something and that
something is going to be the output so
let's enter that now this is slightly
sort of we're still figuring out the so
I'm adding this function here that I've
defined I'm gonna add it to the to the
system and then I've got a function here
that's calling it so I can do that
and now I can you know my function
executes and it works for you know sort
of you know an integer but what's kind
of nice is this function is defined
polymorphically so here I'm going to
feed it to a packed array of reals and a
you know the inferencing system does the
figures all
and so now this version of the function
works for real numbers so this means a
little bit of code goes a long way so
that's that's that's quite quite quite
useful and in these quantifiers
there's cut we kind of have an elaborate
language this is a simple case but you
can put constraints on on these
variables that have to be met in order
for the type to to work now right talk
about some programming examples so one
of the things that we want to use this
compiler for is for programming and I
want to try and give some idea of its
potential so one of the things I wanted
to in fact I gave a talk at Microsoft
Research in Cambridge in England earlier
in the year and some guy at the back put
his hand up and he had some questions
about quicksort it turned out it was
Tony Hoare who is the original developer
of quicksort so I very sorry you know I
don't have so then I thought right let's
let's do quicksort that's that that
would be and so quicksort it's quite a
good algorithm because it's
representative of a big class of problem
solving because it uses a strategy
called divide and conquer so so in
quicksort I've tried to sketch this out
what you do is you partition your
sorting your data
you partition it somehow into two halves
and then you work on so here's your
partition function you do the partition
and then you do the sorting on you know
the low side and the high side and you
keep doing that and this is a good this
is has has good you know this is going
to work efficiently
you know it's divide and conquer
typically has like an N log n sort of
property now so here's the
implementation I'm not necessarily
asking you to read all of this except
we're using we
these closures were using recursive
functions but this is a quicksort that
we can we can implement now I can
actually that same function I can give
it to a you know it's the uncompelled
version works but let's come and compile
it so we compile the function
did you B generate a compiled version of
this and there we go and then we apply
it it also sorts now the advantage that
we've got is we've made this faster so
here I've got 10 to the 5 and this is
the uncompelled version which takes 6.5
seconds and this is the compiled version
so we've got a very significant speed up
of of timings now you might say there's
a built-in sort in Mathematica and
you're right there is a built-in sort so
how does that compare let's do a bigger
bigger version so this is my compiled
version that took one second and this is
the built-in sort so that's still that's
quite a bit faster now let me assure you
the built-in sort is not twenty lines of
code it's hundreds of lines of code this
quicksort is very very simplistic
usually when you're sorting you do
divide and conquer down some size and
then you switch strategies etc so I'm
not totally disheartened about that but
just to prove I'm really not
disheartened I'm going to cheat a little
bit so now I'm going to do something
that's a little bit more like the
internal version of quicksort because
what that does is it doesn't work on
this sort of pact array thing it takes
the data out of the packed rows and it
works on that well we can do that in the
compile function so we're doing this
we're getting the raw data and then
we're going to operate on that so now
this this won't work in the evaluator
but we can compile this and go and we
apply it and this works so now when we
compare this with the hand coded version
so this is the compiled version and this
is the so now we've got down we're still
a little bit a little bit slower than
the you know we're you know factor of
1.5 but I think factor of 1.5 to come to
carefully is not rob you ever wrote that
the sorting it's a merge sort in in
quicksort is just like less lines of
code and Tony asked about quicksort but
I think I think that's pretty cool that
we can write in 20 lines of code
something that gets within you know as
fast as that with carefully handwritten
the C code so I think that's that's kind
of exciting now really what we want to
do is you know we had to cheat a bit
here what we really need to do is to
take the generic packed array version
and add optimizations to it to turn that
into into this and that's that's totally
practical for us to be able to have
optimizations to do that but oh yeah
absolutely
butts in we could yeah quicksort lends
itself to parallelism very nicely and
having you know in this sort of access
to you know make make it simple to write
code means you can write complicated
code without pulling your hair out or
you know jumping off a cliff or
something you know and and Wolfram
language programmers have never been
able to write fast code like this for
common algorithms so I think that's
quite quite exciting yes we have built
in sort but sort is you know there are
like pH
these on phd's that people you know
sorting is such a core fundamental thing
I think it's exciting that we can we
tweak we can work with that now I'm
going to Holtz now and switch gears to
Brenton who's going to show you some
work that he's been working on so don't
go away